hi everyone Sal Khan here and I'm
excited to announce that Khan Migo our
generative AI powered tutor on Khan
Academy is now generally available and
this is especially powerful as we go
into back to school that if you have
conmigo your student has it on their
Khan Academy account that they are going
to be fully supported they can ask
questions not just on their Khan Academy
work about anything that they see in
their schoolwork but it will not cheat
it will not do their homework for them
but it will provide support like a great
tutor would but it goes beyond what a
traditional tutor would do my
background's in computer science and
using this with my own kids I found it
to be a better programming tutor than I
can be it also does things like academic
coaching it can actually give feedback
on students college essays it can
simulate historical characters it can
simulate literary characters it can do
creative exercises with the student
where they could write a story together
and your student could even talk to the
characters in the story now is it not
for profit our mission is free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere but we are having to charge for
conmigo it is nine dollars a month and
we have to charge that because the
computation costs of generative AI are
actually quite expensive and this is an
experience I want to be very clear it's
built off of The Cutting Edge AI
technology we're not skimping on any
dimension of the quality I think people
are surprised by the quality of the math
and how much we've been able to reduce
some of the rough spots that generative
AI has historically had the guard rails
that we've put in not only does it not
cheat but you as a parent if your
student's under 18
can monitor what's going on can be
actively notified if anything suspicious
is going on so if you want to help
support your student this coming school
year in their academics and Beyond think
about getting kind of eagle for them he
actually offers step-by-step
instructions but not to the point where
it gives the answers to the student but
it guides them enough where if the
student reads and goes along with it it
actually helps them achieve the answer
without giving it to them it's almost
like your own little personal virtual
assistant with you at all times it gives
them an ability to be self-sufficient in
a way so it's really great tool and I
think Khan Academy is leading us through
that path let's support the kids let's
manage it let's monitor it so that then
we can allow the educational world to
look at how can this really impact
education and how can it make it better
buy-in is so important like student
engagement is the key to education if
the students are able to ask the
personalized questions and it gives an
answer that's relevant to them they're
going to feel more empowered do the work
and feel inspired to try to learn these
things that otherwise they might say
what's the point